three amazing health benefits of
shiitake mushrooms shiitake mushroom is
an edible mushroom native to East Asia
and it has numerous health benefits
number one it's good for the heart
shiitake contains numerous compounds
like editor Deneen sterols and beta
glucans which help to lower the
cholesterol levels in the blood animal
Studies have proven that extracts from
this mushroom help to lower blood
pressure and development of block in the
artery walls number two it has cancer
fighting properties shiitake mushrooms
contain several compounds that have been
shown to invade the growth of cancer
cells including latinins beta blubens
and ergothionine chitake mushrooms have
been studied for their potential to
treat a variety of cancers including
breast prostate and lung cancer number
three it can help to fight obesity
Studies have reported that beta glucans
and irritated any in present in shiitake
can increase hetaiti reduce food intake
delay absorption and reduce plasma lipid
levels which can help to fight obesity
shiitake mushrooms are low in calories
and fat and they are a good source of
protein fiber and antioxidants remember
to stay curious and